5 Types of Depressive Disorders
Depression is a very misunderstood disorder
People will tend to stereotype depression and make it seem as though you are typically sad all the time and hate the world
But that is far from the truth
Depression has sub disorders that will have different symptoms intensities and causes here are the different types of depression
Disruptive Mood Dysregulation Disorder
If you tend to have continuous outbursts of temper either physical or verbal and it happens three times a week
That is one of the symptoms for Disruptive Mood Dysregulation Disorder
Other symptoms that you could experience are feeling sad or moody besides the anger three times a week or
having severe outbursts. It's more likely that you have this disorder
if these symptoms have occurred for more than a year, or if the symptoms started before the age of 10
Another sub disorder of depression is major depressive disorder which can also be known as clinical depression
Those with this disorder may have an episode for longer periods of time while others may only have had an episode once in their life
People with MDD have the following symptoms for nearly a two-week span and it will usually arise everyday
Feeling hopeless sad or numb;
Decreased motivation for things that they used to like;
Increased or decreased appetite which could lead to weight gain or loss respectively;
Changes in sleep; Fatigue; Being unable to concentrate;
Forgetfulness; Thoughts of death or suicide;
Suicide attempts and self-harm.
MDD can be mixed with different disorders like anxiety;
melancholic features; catatonia; peripartum onset; psychotic features and seasonal patterns.
Persistent depressive disorder also known as dysthymia is an ongoing
depressive disorder the symptoms are not as clear as MDD,
however the symptoms usually happen almost every day for two years in adults, and at least one year for children and adolescents
The symptoms that go along with dysthymia are appetite change; change in sleep cycle; low energy; poor self-esteem;
feelings of hopelessness; bad concentration; forgetfulness and lack of motivation
Dysthymia can be mixed with other disorders just like MDD; it can also range in levels of severity
Premenstrual dysphoric disorder is disabling approximately three to eight percent of women and no one can really figure out why
The following symptoms occur during the menstrual cycle and a usual diagnosis would require at least five of the following symptoms to be present
mood swings;
increased sensitivity;
feelings of hopelessness or being overwhelmed;
anxiety; feeling tired and sluggish; a lack of interest in activities and insomnia or excessive amounts of sleep
The disorder also has physical symptoms such as joint pain; bloating; weight gain; tender breasts and swelling
This disorder will affect school, work and relationships
Substance/medication induced depressive disorder. This disorder is present during the use of medication or during substance abuse
Symptoms include irritability;
Depressive episodes; bad temper; the sense of hopelessness and no interest or pleasure in anything
These symptoms will occur when using the substance or win in withdrawal. Most people use drugs
Or substances to feel better and will usually not notice the symptoms. They have for substance medication and use depressive disorder
Depressive disorder due to another medical condition is another type of depression
arthritis diabetes HIV
Strokes viral infections and much more can cause you to have depression
symptoms can include a persistent depressive mood lack of interest irritability and an elevated or expansive mood
We hope this helps you out if you experience any of these symptoms
Please see your doctor or find someone you trust to talk to especially if your symptoms persist
Thank you for watching. Don't forget to like this video and subscribe to our Channel